good morning everybody i'm paul saginaw
i'm here with our culinary director
jerry jeremy rosenfield
and we're over here in the kitchen at
saginaw's delicatessen inside the
beautiful
circa casino and resort
and uh the big news is today is national
pastrami day
and i know most of you had that on your
calendars but i just wanted to remind
you that it was
and we're going to talk about pastrami
and jeremy's gonna go through
how we construct a plain pastrami
sandwich
uh a pastrami on rye with mustard is the
quinton essential
delicatessen sandwich uh milton berle
is known for saying that if someone goes
into a delicatessen
and orders a pastrami sandwich on white
bread
somewhere a jew dies so
uh you know the big question is uh
what's pastrami
and and corned beef what's the
difference between pastrami and corned
beef
well corned beef is is is is made from
the brisket
of the cow and it's brine
and then it's uh cooked it's either
boiled or cooked with steam
uh here we we cook it with uh with wet
steam
and dry heat for about six hours
pastra and so the corned beef comes in
raw pastrami comes in as a cooked
product
we do cook it a little longer after that
but pastrami is the navel plate
uh just like bacon is from uh the belly
of the
the hog the uh the naval
the pastrami is is from the uh naval or
the belly of the cow
uh you could say uh sometimes it's you
know you could say it's kosher
bacon anyways pastrami is fattier
more flavorful uh and uh
it is also the the navel is also brined
but then it's it's rubbed with a spice
mix coriander
cloves allspice black pepper
and burnt sugar and then it's hung in a
smokehouse and smoked
and it's really just delicious
and when you take care of it properly it
melts in your mouth and so we're going
to make a sandwich here
we start with our rye bread and uh
we our rye bread comes from carlos the
master baker at bond breads
locally here in las vegas and
our rye bread comes in fully cooked
but we put it in the oven
for 12 minutes at 375 we double bake it
so we put a really hard crust on the
outside
and it's warm and chewy on the inside
and then
uh like all our sandwiches the bread is
sliced to order
and uh and then the sandwich is
constructed so jeremy is
putting the mustard on there you gotta
have mustard on a pastrami sandwich
and then he's gonna we have our nice
pastrami
sliced fresh
piled high all that sandwich right there
it down here
here we'll add our freshly cooked chips
made in-house and we'll top it off with
a nice old pickle bag
so there you have it you can't get any
more traditional
for a delicatessen than pastrami on rye
with mustard
uh invite everybody to come down today
actually any day and uh will serve up
some great pastrami sandwiches to you